any Pisa tend to some serious not some
votes of European politics for the
plenary session in Strasbourg the
Commission's work program next year
midterm revisions to the EU use
five-year budget protecting fundamental
rights and naming the sacrifice winner
many MEP say a recent rollback of
democratic values in Poland and Hungary
reflects a wider erosion of fundamental
rights in Europe now they want action
they're calling for a new mechanism to
monitor the state of democracy rule of
law and fundamental rights in EU Member
States on an annual basis and to propose
ways of fixing breaches they'll be
voting on a draft resolution on Tuesday
there are two clear messages to the
Commission on the EU long-term spending
plans more financial headroom to meet
unforeseen crises such as disasters
refugees terrorism or security and a
crisis fund must be well resourced on
Wednesday MEP s discuss a midterm
revision of the 2014 to 2020 budget
known as the multi-annual financial
framework with Commissioner Kristalina
Georgieva they had hoped for more
resources but for the Commission these
remain unchanged and EPS are hoping to
wrap up negotiations by the end of the
year they'll also be voting on the 2017
budget Wednesday also sees a big debate
with jean-claude Juncker and Donald Tusk
presidents of the European Commission
and council respectively on the outcome
of the October summit of heads of state
and government key issues EU Russia
relations including the sanctions regime
expanding European defense options and
the troubled EU Canada trade agreement
cita a bit of brexit no doubt also much
if not all of this will inevitably spill
into 2017 and the Commission's work
programme for next year will come under
scrutiny in a debate on Tuesday alive to
current European political wins MEP say
social rights jobs and security should
head the priorities now in brief some
other items coming up in
a resolution before Parliament on
Wednesday seeks to place mandatory
limits on industrially produced trans
fatty acids which risk cardiovascular
disease Alzheimer's and obesity
following the historic nuclear deal with
Iran MP is what the EU to shift
relations to a new level expanding trade
and the escalating regional tensions the
debate is on Monday and a vote on
Tuesday the threats acts of aggression
and restrictions that journalists face
in Turkey are debated on Wednesday since
the failed coup 90 journalists have been
jailed and more than 2,500 have lost
their jobs finally the winner of the
Sakharov Prize for freedom of thought
2016 is to be announced
the candidates are kin doomed a former
editor-in-chief of the leading Turkish
opposition newspaper Chum who yet
Mustafa Jamil F champion four decades of
crimean tatar rights and jointly Nadia
Murad Bassett AAHA and Lamia Angie Bosch
are both advocates for the Yazidi
community in Iraq and survivors of
sexual enslavement by so-called Islamic
state the announcement is due to be made
on Thursday and that's it for this
roundup of key moments in plenary enjoy
the week